[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you, Judy, the master
of the art of introductions.
You make us all sound so
good and accomplished.
It's quite remarkable.
Also quickly would like to
thank Dean Lizabeth Cohen--
I think Liz is there--
for your leadership of
the Radcliffe Institute.
The entire fellowship
program staff,
especially Rebecca Haley--
thank you, Rebecca, for all
your administrative brilliance.
And all the other
incredible people
top to bottom who collectively
make the Radcliffe
such a special place.
All the fellows--
see you in the crowd
here-- thank you for your
collegiality, brilliance,
and intellectual curiosity.
You're all doing
incredibly amazing work,
even though I wish someone was
working on a project on time
suspension, because
the time is really
going by way too quickly.
But in the time that
we have this afternoon,
I would like to tell a story.
It's a story about
war and the challenges
of being African-American.
It's a story about
race and democracy,
about history and memory.
It's a story about hope
and disillusionment,
about optimism and tragedy.
It's a story that spans
almost two decades,
from one World War to
the next, and features
as its central character
arguably the most significant
black intellectual
in American history.
But it may be helpful
first to take you back
to a moment in October
of the year 2000.
A young graduate
student just embarking
on research for a dissertation
on African-American soldiers
in World War I is
at the University
of Massachusetts Amherst.
The papers of WEB Du Bois
are housed in the library's
special collections department.
This graduate student had
very responsibly in advance
gone through the finding
aid and saw a reference
to Du Bois World
War I materials.
He was intrigued.
He goes to the library.
He asks the archivist
to see this collection.
He's expecting a few folders,
maybe even a whole box
if he's lucky.
Instead, the archivist returns
with six microfilm reels.
Hmm.
Now what could this possibly be?
He loads the first reel--
for those of us
old enough to know
what microfilm reels actually
are; I'm dating myself,
I'm not that young, sorry--
loads the reel and turns the
machine, and slowly forwards
the film to the first frame.
And this is what he sees.
Now if you haven't
figured it out yet,
the young graduate
student is me.
And what I was looking
at was the table
of contents of an
unpublished manuscript
by WEB Du Bois on the black
experience in World War
I. This was followed by
the actual manuscript--
as I kept reeling, followed
by the actual manuscript,
along with all of Du
Bois' research materials
and correspondence
related to the project.
Needless to say, I was shocked,
thrilled, and overwhelmed.
As I began to immerse
myself in this archive
and learn more about it,
I realized that it was not
completely unknown.
Some Du Bois scholars had
mentioned it in their works,
with a few-- most notably,
historians Jennifer Keene
and David Levering Lewis--
actually exploring
its significance.
But most people when I
tell them of Du Bois'
unpublished manuscript
are surprised
as I was that day
in October of 2000.
Why this is the
case, given all that
has been written about Du Bois,
would be a fascinating story
to tell.
So, Judy, I might need
another year at the Radcliffe.
You're going to have to
hook me up, for real.
Also, as you can
probably imagine
from just looking at the table
of contents, the manuscript
itself is truly fascinating.
Piecing the manuscript
together and analyzing it
would make for another
fascinating project.
So, two years, Judy?
Huh?
You wish, all right.
But I'm also fascinated with
the story behind this book.
What happened?
Why did Du Bois write it?
What was it about?
Why did he spend so
much time working on it?
Why did it remain
incomplete and unpublished?
Why is it important?
So as best I can in the
next 40 minutes or so,
let me tell you the story
of The Wounded World--
WEB Du Bois, African-Americans,
and the History of World War I.
"From the branches of
the National Association
for the Advancement of Colored
People to WE Burghardt Du Bois,
writer, scholar, seer,
on his fiftieth birthday,
February 23, 1918.
Given in affectionate
appreciation
of his great gifts,
and gratitude
for the consecration
of these gifts
to the service of his race."
So read the inscription on the
silver cup presented to Du Bois
at a New York civic
club gala celebrating
his half century of life.
Born on February 23, 1868 in
Great Barrington, Massachusetts
to Mary Silvina, Du Bois
in his mind and heart
was truly destined to serve
his race a young prodigy,
throughout grade
school he attended
and graduated from Fisk
University in Tennessee
before moving back to
Massachusetts, where he earned
a second undergraduate degree
from some school called Harvard
University.
He stayed at Harvard to
pursue a doctorate in history,
briefly interrupted by a
two-year transformative stint
at the University of Berlin.
And there's Du Bois right
there, second top realm.
Returned back to Harvard, where
he completed his dissertation
in 1895 titled The Suppression
of African Slave Trade
in America, becoming the
first African-American
to obtain a Ph.D. From Harvard.
He would quickly
establish himself
as black America's foremost
scholar and interrogator
of the race problem.
In 1903, he published
what is widely
considered the
most important book
in the history of
African-American letters,
The Souls of Black Folk.
Du Bois also helped
lay the groundwork
for what we now
commonly recognize
as the modern civil
rights movement.
In 1905, he founded
the Niagara Movement
to challenge the accommodations
program of Booker T.
Washington, and in 1909
helped co-found the NAACP,
where he served as editor
of its magazine, The Crisis.
On the eve of the
World War, in terms
of intellect and influence
Du Bois had few rivals.
Du Bois closely
followed the World War
from the opening guns of August.
"Yet in a very real sense
Africa is a prime cause
of this terrible
overturning of civilization
which we have lived
to see," he wrote
in his landmark 1915
Atlantic Monthly article,
The African Roots of War.
He pinpointed the origins of
the conflict in the competition
amongst the European
belligerence
for imperial control of
Africa and its people.
France, England, and
Belgium all certainly
had blood on their hands.
But thirsty for
global domination,
Germany, in Du Bois'
opinion, posed a grave threat
to the world's darker races.
The Allies had to win.
So when the United
States entered the war
in April of 1917,
Du Bois, unlike many
of his socialist friends in
and outside of the NAACP,
was not opposed.
He argued that it
presented an opportunity
for African-Americans to stake
claim to their citizenship
and bring meaning to
Woodrow Wilson's claim
that the world must be
made safe for democracy.
Black people had
fought in the past,
and now they would do
so again with hopes
that the two warring
ideals of being black
and of being American, that
Du Bois famously articulated
in The Souls of Black Folk,
would at last be reconciled.
Du Bois threw himself
into the war effort,
encouraging African-Americans
as soldiers and civilians
to demonstrate their loyalty
on and off the battlefield.
But white supremacy
tested his patriotism--
along with other
African-Americans he had
to reckon with moments like the
unjust execution of 13 black
soldiers following a racial
shootout in Houston, Texas,
and especially the East St.
Louis pogrom of July 1917,
which left hundreds
of black people dead .
While African-Americans
certainly
pleaded for Woodrow
Wilson to make America
safe for democracy,
they also demanded it,
as evidenced by the silent
protest parade in response
to the East St. Louis
pogrom, with Du Bois marching
in the front.
So when Joe Spingarn,
former chairman of the NAACP
and one of Du Bois'
closest friends,
approached him in
early June of 1918
with an offer to become a
captain in the War Department's
military intelligence
division, he
had a momentous and potentially
career-defining choice to make.
Du Bois knew that
this appointment
would arouse suspicions.
But he believed that,
as he wrote in a letter
to the director of the
military intelligence division,
his decision to accept
the offer reflected
"no inconsistency with
or change of attitude
from my life long
work and opinions."
Indeed, he viewed his attitude
as one of "far-reaching
patriotism."
But just to make sure no
lingering reservations existed
about his loyalty, he wrote
Close Ranks for the July
issue of The Crisis.
The Great War represented
the crisis of the world,
Du Bois began.
He argued that however
distant the war seemed,
black people had no ordinary
interest in the outcome.
For this reason,
African-Americans
had to make their
allegiances clear.
Let us not hesitate.
Let us, while this war lasts,
forget our special grievances
and close our ranks
shoulder to shoulder
with our own white
fellow citizens
and the Allied nations that
are fighting for democracy.
We make no ordinary
sacrifice, but we
make it gladly and
willingly with our eyes
lifted to the hills.
Closed Ranks unleashed a
firestorm of criticism.
The Boston civil
rights activist--
and one-time friend--
William Monroe Trotter
labeled Du Bois,
among other insults, a
rank quitter of the fight
for rights.
From coast to coast, in
newspapers in barbershops,
many African-Americans branded
Du Bois as self-serving at best
and at worst a
traitor to the race.
For a man who had committed his
life to the cause of freedom
and justice for black people,
no charge could be more cutting.
The captaincy offer
ultimately crumbled,
but the uproar and damage
to his radical credentials
left Du Bois deeply scarred.
Du Bois' attempt to
strike a grand bargain
with the federal government
and American democracy
seem yet more misguided in light
of the US military's treatment
of black servicemen,
a history which
Judy touched upon which
I'll elaborate a little bit
more detail.
Approximately 380,000
African-American soldiers
served in the racially
segregated United States Army.
The majority of black
troops in France
unglamorously labored in
the services of supply,
loading and unloading
ships, digging ditches,
laying railroad tracks,
and burying dead bodies.
The army reluctantly
agreed to the creation
of two black combat units,
the 92nd Division composed
of draftees and
the 93rd Division
made up largely black
National Guardsmen.
While the 93rd Division compiled
a stellar combat record,
the 92nd Division became, as
Du Bois later described it,
the storm center of
the Negro troops.
Racist white commanders and
deliberate neglect from the War
Department doomed the
performance of the division
from the start, While its black
officers, Du Bois' shining
examples of Talented Tenth
manhood and racial leadership,
endured humiliation
after humiliation.
African-Americans could point
to several notable battlefield
triumphs and moments
of racial pride.
But for most black
soldiers, the war
for democracy, that Du Bois had
so enthusiastically champion
devolved into a personal hell.
As the end of the war neared, Du
Bois, his credibility tattered,
his leadership in question, sat
in the most precarious position
of his otherwise-illustrious
career.
Then, quite unexpectedly,
an opportunity
presented itself, one
that would profoundly
impact Du Bois' life for
the next two decades.
At the October, 1918 board
of directors meeting,
the NAACP proposed Du Bois
spearhead production of a book
on the history of the black
experience in the war.
He leapt at the opportunity.
The scholar in Du
Bois was intrigued.
But more important, here
was a chance for redemption.
As a way of demonstrating
his continued ability
to organize and
lead, he initially
hoped that the book would
be a collaborative effort.
He had two co-authors in mind--
Carter G. Woodson,
confounder of the Association
for the Study of Negro
Life and History,
and Emmett J. Scott, the
former secretary to Booker T.
Washington, who had recently
served as a special assistant
to the Secretary of War.
But Du Bois' influence
had its limits.
Woodson, arguably
the most prominent
African-American historian in
the nation next to Du Bois,
insisted on receiving sole
credit for the project.
Scott, arguably the most
influential African-American
in the government
during the war,
had plans to write his own book.
At stake was the
right to call oneself
the historian of
the black experience
in the war and the
leadership stature
that went along with it.
This was a fight that Du
Bois absolutely had to win.
Undaunted, he set
his sights on France,
where, as he would later
write, the destinies of mankind
center.
On December the
1st, 1918, Du Bois
departed from
Hoboken, New Jersey,
as part of the official
press delegation
accompanying President Woodrow
Wilson to the peace conference
at Versailles.
Du Bois spent three
months in France.
He organized a landmark
Pan-African Congress
in February of 1919.
His principal mission, however,
was to conduct research
for the NAACP war history.
He toured the battlefields
and saw the trenches
where soldiers of
the 92nd Division
fought until the
11th hour of November
the 11th as the armistice
went into effect.
He visited the encampments
and experienced,
as he recalled, a touch of war.
Most important, he talked with
black soldiers and officers.
With military intelligence
following his every move,
Du Bois absorbed tale after
tale of discrimination, slander,
and abuse inflicted
upon black servicemen
at the hands of
the American army.
A longtime friend, Virgil
Boutte, served as his guide.
Boutte was a captain
in the 92nd Division,
who had been constantly
humiliated by his fellow white
officers, court-martialed on
false charges of inefficiency,
seriously injured in
combat, and placed--
despite his officer status--
in a segregated hospital ward
with regular enlisted men.
He entrusted his diary to Du
Bois, where in one pained entry
Boutte scrawled,
"no nation on earth
has ever hated a group as
the Americans hate Negroes."
"Never in my life have I
heard such an astounding
series of stories," Du
Bois wrote from France
in a January, 1919 letter
to his NAACP colleagues.
You have not the
faintest conception what
these men have been through.
It is not only
astonishing, but it
will arouse every ounce
of sympathetic blood
in your veins.
He knew what needed to be done.
The task ahead was clear.
His commitment had been steeled.
"I can say solemnly and
without hesitation--
the greatest and most
pressing & most important work
for the NAACP is the
collection writing
& publication of the history
of the Negro troops in France."
Du Bois returned to the United
States enraged, embarrassed,
and determined.
He could not help
but to question
if his decision to
encourage black people
to throw body and soul into the
war effort had been worthwhile.
He channeled his
frustrations along
with the anguish of the
African-American servicemen
he encountered in France
into the postwar issues
of the crisis.
In the May, 1919 issue,
he informed readers
about his mission
in France, exposed
the racism of the US
Army, and defended
the honor of black troops.
The highlight, however,
was returning soldiers,
as his words would
serve as a rallying
cry for African-Americans
in the aftermath of the war.
"We return.
We return from fighting.
We return fighting."
History would be Du
Bois' central battlefront
in the struggle over
the meaning of the war.
"Most American
Negroes do not realize
that the imperative
duty of the moment
is to fix in history the
status of our Negro troops,"
he wrote in an editorial
announcing his plans
to produce the study of the
black experience in the war.
To assist in this cause, he
tasked readers of The Crisis
to help in the compilation
of this history.
Elsewhere, he specifically asked
black soldiers and officers to,
in his words, "see that
the editor of The Crisis
receives documents, diaries, and
information such as will enable
The Crisis history of the
war to be complete, true,
and unanswerable."
Letters, diaries, photographs,
official military documents,
and personal memoirs quickly
flooded Du Bois' office.
In a note to the boys
detailing his battles
with racism while
serving overseas,
Sergeant Charles Isum
of the 92nd Division
expressed his pleasure that
quote "someone has the nerve
and backbone to tell the
public the unvarnished facts
concerning the injustice,
discrimination,
and Southern prejudice
practices by the white Americans
against black
Americans in France."
Du Bois promised that his
book, tentatively titled
The Negro in the Revolution
of the 20th Century,
would appear by the fall.
Black veterans like Charles
Isum hoped that Du Bois
would tell their story.
Du Bois intended to
serve as their muse.
Generating further
excitement, Du Bois
published a remarkable
article entitled
An Essay Toward a History of
the Black Man in the Great War,
a tantalizing preview of the
larger book he planned to write
and a preemptive
strike against attempts
to distort and marginalize
African-Americans
in the history and
memory of the war.
He wrote, "there is
not a black soldier who
is glad he went, glad to
fight for France, the only
real democracy, glad to
have a new, clear vision
of the real inner spirit
of American prejudice.
The day of camouflage is past."
Du Bois' certainty
would be severely tested
throughout the summer of 1919.
From Washington, D.C.; to
Chicago; to Phillips County,
Arkansas, race riots
and full-scale massacres
exploded throughout the country.
The number of
lynchings skyrocketed.
Black veterans found
themselves quite literally
fighting for their lives.
James Weldon Johnson
labeled these bloody months
the "red Summer."
The horror of the summer was
seared into Du Bois' memory,
as he would remember
1919 as a year of--
in his words-- "extraordinary
and unexpected reaction."
Du Bois used his
1920 book Darkwater
to reflect on the
war, its appalling
aftermath, and his
growing disillusionment.
He minced no words.
In a chapter titled The
Souls of White Folk,
Du Bois wrote, "let
me say this again
and emphasize it and leave no
room for mistaken meaning--
the World War was primarily the
jealous and avaricious struggle
for the largest share in
exploiting darker races."
Du Bois also asked a
remarkable question--
"How great a failure
and a failure in what
does the World War betoken?"
On both a personal and
intellectual level,
it was a question
that he had to answer.
Du Bois therefore
committed himself
to the NAACP war project.
He devoted significant time
throughout much of 1920
and into 1922 to drafting
several potential chapters
for what he confidently
believed would
be the definitive history of
the black experience in the war.
Still exhilarated from
his Pan-African Congresses
of 1919 and 1921,
he wrote chapters
on the experiences
of black troops
in the French and
British armies,
as well as a chapter musing on
the future of the black world
in the wake of the war.
Du Bois' early
chapter drafts also
reflected an attempt
to try and find
redemptive value in the global
catastrophe and his place
in it.
This was clear in a chapter
titled The Challenge, which
summarized the difficult
choices African-Americans
and himself faced in
supporting the war.
"For the moment-- and
it was but a moment,
it passed, but for
a moment the country
seemed to rise to its
mightiest stature."
Addressing his
disillusionment, he
mused, "I have been
called bitter, I am bitter
but here I saw all
the hurts, the tears,
the pain as in one country
and that country was mine."
Du Bois was glad that at
least for this one brief
fleeting emancipatory
moment, he could call himself
an American, that
he and the race
"Could think with the nation
and not as a mere group.
We could rise to
mighty selfishness.
The nation, our
country, the allies
as champions of the little
hurt folk, democracy."
The only way he could
explain his delusion
was to plead temporary insanity.
"We were mad-- that is
the only word for it,
we were mad and let it
not excuse us to say
that the madness was divine."
But he still refused
to completely admit
that he was wrong.
"How in the end did all this
set with our inner problem?"
he pondered.
"After all it was
not a mere bargain--
it was a moving wish."
Du Bois pressed ahead
to finish his book.
He held out hope that despite
a lack of financial support
and numerous other
commitments and distractions--
future book projects,
Crisis editorials,
speaking engagements,
Pan-African Congresses,
a venomous feud
with Marcus Garvey--
it would soon be completed.
But the worsening conditions
facing African-Americans
and peoples of African descent
throughout the diaspora
caused him to further struggle
with the war's individual
and collective meaning.
The walls of caste segregation
seemed to only grow higher.
Racial violence became
more and more horrific.
The grip of Europe
on Africa, in spite
of his Pan-African
Congresses only tightened.
And then there was
personal tragedy.
In January of 1922, Du Bois
lost his closest friend
and the man who best
embodied the quest
to reconcile race and country,
Colonel Charles Young.
Young was the
highest-ranking black officer
in the army and black
America's military hero.
He had been unjustly
retired from active service
during the war for
dubious health reasons
to prevent him from
becoming a general.
It broke his heart.
The army reinstated him after
the armistice-- conveniently--
and assigned him to Liberia.
He would die in a
Nigerian hospital.
Over a year after his
death, Young's body
was finally returned
to the United States
and buried with full honors in
Arlington National Cemetery.
But Du Bois could not
forgive the government
for what he described
in his words
the "inexcusable crime" of
sending Young to Liberia.
"For if Charles Young's
blood pressure was too high
for him to go to France," Du
Bois wrote in an editorial,
"why was it not too
high for him to be
sent to the
even-more-arduous duty
in the swamps of West Africa?"
"God rest his sickened
soul," Du Bois concluded,
"but give our souls no rest
if we let the truth concerning
him droop overlaid with lies."
This ugly reminder
of the war's legacy
provided further validation
for the new title
Du Bois had by this time
given his book, The Black Man
and the Wounded World.
As the title reflected, Du
Bois' initial conceptualization
of the war as a potentially
revolutionary moment
in the reconstruction
of global race relations
have evolved to an
interpretation of the conflict
as one of the darkest moments
in modern world history.
The war was a global tragedy.
This sense of the war
as tragic was not solely
about the incredible loss of
life and physical destruction.
For Du Bois, it also had to
do with the strengthening
of white supremacy and
continued economic exploitation
of peoples of African descent.
No surprise then that
he described the war
in the opening chapter
of his book manuscript
as "a Scourge, an evil, a
retrogression to Barbarism,
a waste, a wholesale murder."
Du Bois' public
announcement in 1924
of The Black Man and
the Wounded World
sparked renewed public
interest in the book.
Encouraged, he
began writing again.
By 1926, he had drafted the
bulk of his envisioned chapters.
The book finally seemed on
the verge of completion.
But he needed help.
He had a massive
manuscript that,
judged by his high scholarly
and artistic standards,
still required significant
work in revision.
Without time and
editorial assistants,
he felt that he could
not complete the project.
Seeking support,
he sent inquiries
to nearly every major
philanthropic organization--
the Rockefeller Foundation,
the Russell Sage Foundation,
the Slater Fund, the Julius
Rosenwald Fund, the Carnegie
Endowment.
If it was around,
I'm sure he would
have applied to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
All have expressed
courtesy interest,
but all ultimately
offered their regrets.
But beyond the practical
obstacle of financial support--
or lack thereof--
Du Bois faced an even bigger
and more daunting challenge--
himself.
If the war he had
supported was indeed
a failure, as he pondered
as early as 1920,
a war that had no positive
outcome, then perhaps
his book languishing
and in limbo
was destined for a similar fate.
Du Bois' sizable ego,
however, would not
allow for the possibility.
As he agonized over what
to do with his book,
many of the same
veterans who had once
viewed Du Bois as a
savior now grew restless
and requested the return
of their personal letters,
photographs, memoirs,
and other ephemera
they had loaned him
so many years ago.
James Johnson, a Harlem
attorney and former Sergeant
in the 92nd division,
wanted his stuff back.
Du Bois, stubbornly
convinced his book would soon
be completed, refused.
Eventually, the matter
will be returned to you,
Du Bois told Johnson
in a 1928 letter.
It cannot be returned now and
I cannot set any exact date
as to when it can be returned.
Johnson would have none of it.
Assuming that he was,
in Johnson's words,
dealing with a
gentleman of honor who
would spare no effort in his
endeavor to keep his word,
Johnson respond to
Du Bois, I trust
that you will see the expediency
of an amicable adjustment
of this matter, thereby
saving all parties concerned
the needless expense, loss of
time, and further embarrassment
that proceedings to compel
compliance will entail.
And Martha, I'm sure you know
where that is headed, right?
Facing the threat of a lawsuit
and public humiliation,
Du Bois somehow found the
time to locate Johnson's items
and return them.
But the majority of black
veterans were not as fortunate.
Du Bois may not have felt guilty
about his treatment of Johnson
and other black veterans,
but he certainly
harbored guilt about his
decision to support the war.
In 1930, Du Bois participated
in a published discussion
for the magazine The World
Tomorrow on the war guilt
debate that was consuming
the historical profession.
The debate-- if Germany was
solely responsible for the war
and if American
intervention was justified.
In his reply to the
editor, he admitted
to being swept off my
feet during the World War
by the emotional
response of America
to what seemed to be
a great call to duty.
The costs had been
immeasurably high.
"Instead of a war to end war,
or a war to save democracy,
we found ourselves during
and after the war descending
to the meanest and most
sordid of selfish actions,
and we find ourselves today
nearer moral bankruptcy
than we were in 1914."
Then, surprisingly but with
a disclaimer, he admitted,
"I am ashamed of my
own lack of foresight."
"And yet, war is so tremendous
and terrible a thing
that only those who
actually experience it
can know its real meaning."
Du Bois was willing to
acknowledge his error
in supporting the
war, but still sought
to rationalize his decision
by casting himself as one
of the war's countless victims.
It was not his fault.
Never content to
remain unproductive,
Du Bois turned to
other projects,
including his most notable
published work of history,
Black Reconstruction.
The war, however,
stayed on his mind.
In a letter to Alfred Harcourt
proposing Black Reconstruction
in 1931, Du Bois
informed the editor
quote "I'm going to add
next year as a second volume
The Black Man and the Wounded
World, that is the part which
Negro troops took in the
World War and its significance
for the world today."
Harcourt responded to Du
Bois that the proposed study
on reconstruction
quote "promises
a really interesting book."
He made no mention of
the book on World War.
Following the 1935 publication
of Black Reconstruction,
Du Bois again returned to
The Black Man and the Wounded
World.
A glimmer of hope appeared
in March of that year
when he secured a $600 grant
from the Social Science
Research Council.
By this time, Du Bois' politics
had moved further to the left
and he began to envision The
Black Man and the Wounded World
as an explicit lesson about
the horrors of modern warfare.
A trip around the world in 1936
brought even greater clarity
to the new significance
of Du Bois' book.
Thanks to a fellowship
from the Oberlaender Trust,
Du Bois spent seven quite
controversial months abroad,
first visiting Hitler's
Germany, then England, France,
Switzerland, Austria, Russia,
China, and finally imperial
Japan.
He returned to the United
States in December of 1936,
having seen firsthand the
seeds of the next World War.
The need for his book could
not have been more urgent.
This was the moment.
He needed people to see
that the still-open wounds
from the last World War,
infected and festering,
promised an
even-greater disaster
in the very near future.
In his mind, it
was now or never.
Hoping to finally
put the project--
along with the memory
of the war itself--
behind him, Du Bois reached out
to the American Philosophical
Society in March of 1937.
"I began my work in this
field as a conventional study
of the Negro as a soldier
in the World War, he wrote."
But over time, he
explained, "the whole theme
has been expanding and
developing in my min,"
more especially since my trip
around the world in 1936.
He now conceived the
book, in his words,
"on a much broader and
more important scale."
If only he could have time and
leisure, opportunity, to finish
this work, he
pleaded, "I think I
can do something which will have
influence on future knowledge
with regard to war
and colored people."
$7,500 would be
sufficient, he thought--
that's quite a bit of
money at that time.
The American Philosophical
Society denied his request.
With this final rejection,
Du Bois, disheartened,
grudgingly abandoned hope that
he would finish and publish
his book.
Despite the investment
of almost 20 years,
despite a manuscript
of nearly 800 pages,
The Black Man and
the Wounded World,
Du Bois' epic history of the
black experience in the First
World War, would never
see the light of day.
So this could very well
be the end of the story.
But we are left with
the question of why.
Why didn't Du Bois finish
The Black Man and the Wounded
World?
I would argue that
Du Bois suffered
from a sort of
intellectual shell shock
when it came to writing about
and rationalizing a war defined
by its irrationality.
In his semi-autobiographical
1940 book, Dusk of Dawn,
he wrote, "in my
effort to reconstruct
in memory my thought and
the fight of the National
Association for the
Advancement of Colored People
during the World War,
I have difficulty
in thinking clearly."
Now for those of us who
are familiar with Du Bois,
not being able to think
clearly is probably
something we wouldn't
associate with him.
He go on to lament that the
whole history of the American
Negro and other black
folk in the World War
has never been written.
He recalled his time in France
and the mass of documents
he had collected over the years.
"They deserve
publication"-- he wrote--
"not simply as a part
of the Negro's history,
but as an unforgettable lesson
in the spiritual lesions
spiritual lesions
of race conflict
during a critical period
of American history."
By the 1940s, it was clear
that the spiritual lesions
left on the world by the First
World War had not healed.
Du Bois' own wounds
had not healed either.
In a 1941 letter regarding his
alma mater, Fisk University,
possibly taking a position
of support for American entry
into World War
II, Du Bois wrote,
"I have lived through one period
of deliberate and prolonged
propaganda for war and partially
succumbed to it" until I really
believed that the First World
War was a war to end war
and that the interests of
colored people in particular
were bound up in the
defeat of Germany.
"I have lived to know
better," and my opposition
to war under any
circumstances has
been immeasurably increased.
But even up to the
final years of his life,
Du Bois still sought to
understand why he had supported
the war in the first place.
"I felt for a moment
as the war progressed
that I could be
without reservation
a patriotic American," Du
Bois wrote in an autobiography
posthumously published in 1968.
"I am not sure that I
was right but certainly
my intentions were.
I did not believe in
war, but I thought
that in a fight with
America against militarism
and for democracy we would be
fighting for the emancipation
of the Negro race.
With the Armistice
came disillusion."
That disillusion
stayed with Du Bois
until his death on August
23, 1963 in Accra, Ghana.
The war consumed Du Bois.
It confounded him.
He cannot make sense of it as
both a personal and historical
moment.
He was unable to muster
the intellectual fortitude
and, dare I say, the moral
strength necessary to complete
his book.
His failure embodied
the tragedy of the war
he struggled to write about.
In this sense, The Black
Man and the Wounded World
was Du Bois himself.
But we are also left
with the question
of why does this story matter.
The easy answer is,
well, it's Du Bois.
Anything about Du
Bois matters, right?
But I believe the story
goes beyond Du Bois
and reveals to us the
impact of World War I
on African-Americans,
how it exposed
the core tensions of
African-American identity,
and how it shaped the
history of racial struggle
in the 20th century.
For Du Bois, the history of
World War I was not simply
an intellectual challenge--
it was a profoundly personal,
moral, and ethical challenge
as well.
It still is.
Du Bois understood that
the history of the war
was deeply bound with
the political status
of black people, the
future of democracy,
and the condition of the
world that we live in.
It still is.
So as we ask ourselves
100 years later what
was the significance of
the war, what did it all
mean, why is it
worth remembering,
Du Bois in the black
experience reminds us
that these questions
are not just academic.
They are critical in
2017 to confronting
our current sick democracy,
and necessary to trying to heal
our still-wounded world.
I cannot say for certain, but I
think Du Bois would have agreed
with me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]